a ceremony to mark the departure of more
french troops from northern mali this is
the third military base in the region to
be vacated by french troops during the
last few months
the bases in tassalit and kidal have
already been handed over to malin troops
france has decided to withdraw more than
2 000 of its soldiers from the sahel
region by early next year
but it's not because the so-called war
on terror has been won or domestic peace
has been maintained armed groups linked
to al-qaeda and isil have stepped up
their attacks across the region the
latest of those targeting unpeacekeepers
in northern mali earlier this week
this morning in mali
seven togolese u.n peacekeepers died and
three others were
seriously injured when their vehicle hit
an improvised explosive device in the
bandigyara region of central mali the
peacekeepers were part of a logistics
convoy traveling from dueensa to sivari
interpretations differ as to why france
has decided to reduce its military
footprint in a region that for long
remained part of its strategic presence
in africa outstanding however is the
level of unease between paris and bamako
since the overthrow of mali's
democratically elected president ibrahim
bakar keta in a military coup last
august
france along with the au and other
regional bodies condemned the takeover
of power by force attempts to persuade
the new leaders to restore power to
civilians have failed
so have attempts to speed up a process
that could lead to an election in the
next few months reports the coup leaders
are in secret talks with a russian
private security force known as the
wagner group has worsened political
tensions with france and mali's allies
within the group of five neighboring
countries france began redeploying its
military after a surge of attacks in
mali burkina faso and niger
french troops however continue to
operate in the city of gao one of the
hot spots in northern mali
france says they'll provide support to
you and peacekeepers in the region
two thousand of those peacekeepers
remain in timbuktu after the french
withdrawal
both they and malian troops in the area
are facing frequent attacks by armed
groups after nine years of french and
u.n military intervention the situation
in mali is still as precarious as ever
muhammad